Speaker 1: Red states across the country are
continuing to pass restrictive abortion measures
with the idea that they can be challenged up to
the high court or that they can just be outright
allowed to stand if and when Roe versus Wade is
overturned. The latest such example comes from
Louisiana with a bill that they have passed,
Governor John Bel Edwards, who is a Democrat,
mind you, but a so-called pro-life Democrat,
he has signed into law Senate Bill 342,
which is a trigger law that will do away with
abortion in almost all circumstances. It does
carve out exceptions for medical futility and
ectopic. Pregnancies, but it does not carve out
exceptions for rape and incest. There's also
a penalty in there for abortion providers with
sentences ranging anywhere from 10 to 15 years in
prison. Luckily, there is no criminal penalty for
women who seek and get abortions in the state,
as has been the trend in many of these bills
in red states across the country lately. The
governor said that he wishes that there was an
exception for rape and incest, but he decided to
sign the bill into law anyway. He explained this
in a statement saying, quote, I am pro-life and
have never hidden from that fact. This does not
belie my belief that there should be an exception
to the prohibition on abortion for victims of rape
and incest. However. Vetoing Senate Bill 342 would
not accomplish that end. In fact, vetoing Senate
Bill 342 would leave fewer exceptions in place
than if the bill becomes law and would further
confuse whether pregnancy begins at fertilization
or implantation. For these reasons, I have signed
Senate Bill 342 into law. Now, I thought that
this story offered an opportunity to talk about
some of the Leafs in logic when it comes to the
right wing view on abortion, particularly when it
comes to not prosecuting women who have abortions,
and also when it comes to carving out exceptions
for rape and incest. So starting with the first
one, most Republicans at this point don't want to
see women prosecuted who have abortions. They
may want to prosecute the medical providers,
but not the women themselves. And to me, that
doesn't really make sense given their logic,
right? Because if you buy into this idea that
abortion is murder, well, shouldn't you hold
accountable not only the person who was actually
doing the murder, but also the person who called
the hit? Like if in this current society, as
things are, not only does a hit man get in trouble
and get prosecuted if they kill someone, also the
person that ordered the hit gets in trouble as
well. So why wouldn't the same be true for a case
having to do with an abortion? Also, the leap in
logic when it comes to Republicans on this issue
has to do with the rape and incest thing because
they argue that life begins at conception. All
life is sacred. God has a plan for everyone. Why
would that not apply to a woman who gets raped?
Now, certainly I don't think she should have to
carry a baby to term and have that be a constant
reminder of the tragic event that happened to her.
But many of these Republicans think that there
should be these exceptions carved out. And to me,
it doesn't really seem to make sense if the
whole reason that they're against abortion is
because they believe that life begins
at conception and they believe that
it's murder to kill a baby in the womb. So given
their logic on these different things, to me, it
just doesn't make all that much sense. And sadly,
no longer are these conversations hypothetical
merely because now we're starting to see abortion
get banned in states across the country. Certainly
that's going to be the case if Roe versus Wade is
indeed overturned. These trigger laws are going to
get enacted like this one in Louisiana. And we're
going to have to have these conversations. And to
my understanding, Republicans simply aren't ready
to have them. So that's the latest on one of these
abortion bills that are being passed in a red
state. And I'm sure there are more to come.